may you won't know I got these from
Costco I don't know if you know but
Cosmo got a great jury selection
what's going on y'all this is e 40 and
this is on the rise rappers good jury
math you know some don't it's just part
of the culture you know most of us come
from the inner city we come from the
gutter it's just something we work hard
for it's like you our occupation so why
not spoil ourselves
people like Slick Rick you know he had
all the jury Biz Markie Big Daddy Kane
Eric B and rock him you know people like
that they you know they had that big
truck jewelry just like them had the
gold grills and all that good stuff you
know the mantronix in our let himself go
way back with it play about 13 14
something real skinny
you know me wasn't and you know that
super spectacular but as I grew you know
things got better
[Music]
there's a barrel change from a Iceman
Nick done right
Iceman Nick on my way familiar with him
you can look him up man they're from
King Johnny's up and Houston they called
me 40 water
so I say man you know they nowadays they
call jury and diamonds they you know
they're calling the trip so with drips
water you feel me
not a lot of people with these not a lot
of people out I should have brought my
best team it's hella big it's just like
two two units two kilo the 41 you know
they called me 40 so I I was like you
know I needed another piece to go with
it just a you know me because it's a new
school look right now what they rocking
with he melted it melted it up real
quick and put forty main and so ago so
they call me 40 water so I go like that
forty water so when I wearing on the
neck I shot a forty he made one smaller
all purpose and did another one longer
my sick with a chain big one with a
donkey robotic you know Dumbo
doesn't my favorite one I refuse to make
it smaller
I might have to but it's held a big this
hella big just dying it out
Iceman Nick did it in 2004-2005 he had
me right
I forgot the prices on these DS is up
there to to all these little diamonds of
each one of these you know I'm saying I
should have I could have brought the
appraisals and all that stuff I got them
all in my drawer I'm sure all my jury
you know oh Jesus sure they you know I
mean I got earthquake insurance on my
house and like that you know I'll be
insured this right here this is a ap I
can rock the AP with it and or I can you
already know just to protect you know
what I mean he's at work and that's all
you really need you know people you know
you it depends on what your flavor is I
was a lot of these people age they never
been mine so I already miss already then
did it a lot of things are trading in
there so what sold to me might be new to
you
so I don't knock nobody says I don't
need too much I just got this and then
could I spend money on a lot of other
things but jury is one of the things we
spent we spend money on in hip hop these
go anywhere from just AP and
like a honey and it plus whatever you
know I'm saying but it iced down and
he's going we're from 90 you know what I
mean
I have Rolexes one when I was a teenager
you know what's the perpetual day day
presidential Rolexes I made out the
whole walk because you know saying I
didn't like I said I've seen it all but
sometimes you just you know just move on
and you know you just get what you you
know some plain stuff sometime you know
what I mean and you know and just just
keep it moving because you find that you
know a lot of surgery is you know like
it don't depreciate as much until you do
crazy stuff to it you know what I mean
but you know for the most part you get
to stuff that's not on
depreciate you know I think Gucci Mane
do
I've been iced out since a little boy I
brought three of my diamond bracelets
take off our set and quavo these are
three amigos everything they do is
platinum all three of these are platinum
right here shout the gucci mane this is
a regular ring you know saying and this
is my wedding ring actually I got to him
but I rock this the most I started off
with a band up in Mary since 1991 you
know I'm saying I ain't afraid to say it
you know a lot of you rappers you know
saying y'all fake it man you know I
might talk about some hard-headed but
just understand it I'm a narrator you
know I'm saying I have the platform to
talk about stories I'm a storyteller
and I mean I'm broadcasting life on
Magazine Street man you know I mean ello
may you won't know I got these from
Costco no seriously custo I don't know
if y'all know know but constable got a
great jury selection and they got a
quality diamonds
you know I know Maine when you can't go
to two jeweler to get your jury clean
you know you use some toothpaste and a
toothbrush and you know I've said when
I'm gonna shower do that right they're
gonna rinse it off with a thing and I'm
gonna say you clean them no I'm saying
come out just like you got them cleaned
at the jeweler this game 201 forty real
spiel 201
[Music]
I'm gonna get a couple more watches but
far as designs and everything I can't I
can't reveal you know the design and
what I'm gonna do next you know it's
gonna be something different because the
40 is different when everybody else go
right he go left always say don't buy
$85,000 car before you buy a house but I
know we rappers and I know if you don't
look like a rapper ain't nobody gonna
want to give you no rap money so you got
a F in order to get the money you got to
look like you got some money so it's the
catch-22 you map it out pray on it and
you'll see what the outcome is